hedge peepee says
how are you i'm doing well how are you
thanks for the polish money
also staffing out of time
oh polish zluty
i'll save it for my
fund my travel fund to poland
i'm rose and stafford
oh good timing it's african-american
time
someone was asking about f3 the other
day f3 is like a very playable move
depends upon prevents knight g4
the approach here is to just develop
and there's a couple traps that like can
fall into
we need to use the fine move
okay i'm gonna
try and keep playing aggressively here
probably end up going for castling in f5
thank you drew drewberman
okay king's attacked
and now
how do i have the most amount of fun
oh there's a really funny line okay so
here i'm going to start with a fork
actually this is a pork
because it's a
it's a pin
and a fork
so it's pork
and now i play this move
and now things are confusing but
basically the queen is hanging
and the rook is hanging
and then after this
i'm going to unleash what's called the
dork have a great day mr rosen oh thank
you
uh white's a qq
the dork is a discovered fork
so i'm dorking my opponents
wow it's a pork and then a dork i don't
think i've ever had a pork dork
now the icing on the cake
would be to castle queenside with mates
which might require playing with my
thanks for the content on here and
youtube
indiana
it's a hundred dollars my degrees are
from there and we are your neighbor next
to illinois oh that's so awesome
thanks so much
wait who was that that was free
how do i say this name who's your husier
hoosier
oh the indian
wait the indiana hoosiers
oh yeah we are kind of neighbors
okay no mercy
made next move
okay that was a fun game
i think i might have to put that on you
too
oh it's too much every child in the
world dreams of getting a fork pork dork
queen side castle mate when they grow up
yeah i didn't i didn't finish with the
queen's side castle mate though
i was gonna say that there is
there's a trap with bishop e6 there's
actually two traps
if white plays d4 or c3
then
it allows black to take on e4
and after takes here here it takes
uh queenie two does not pin the queen to
the king that was the reason i played
bishop e6
so in this position i could take the
rook
um
but that didn't quite happen
also there's like a
there's a youtube channel that made some
funny animation
yeah so if you google
eric rosen mmm
pork
you'll get this one
this video
it's made by this channel called dr bees
he makes like funny animations
and
i was reminded about this because the
position that's shown in this video is
very similar to what i had
it came from an f3 stafford
uh
and the soundtrack was taken from
i think one of my videos so
we'll watch it i have night g3 here
look at this move
knight g3
it's a fork and it's a pin
so it's pork
um
[Music]